so now we resume our afternoon session
and we will have two talks finishing the
roof sketch of the MIP stack was re
result and John will talk about the
second part which includes the BCPs and
introspection alright thanks for the
introduction
yeah so this is joint work with Jay
Kingi Anna not Rajan Tomo vidiq and
Henry um and I'm just gonna start by
kind of reminding everyone the
definition of MIP
so MIP is the complexity class so this
is not I might be starred just MIP it's
a classical complexity class that you
would consider if you asked the question
what can to prove or verifier with
interaction and the way this is
typically modeled as you have a verifier
that sits in the middle there's some
computational problem l that I would
like to solve and an input an instance
of that problem X and I want to know if
X is in the language L or not and maybe
the language L is very complicated to
solve and the verifier is simple in
polynomial time and so that might be a
problem and so on this model we augment
the verifier with the help of two
prefers ooh are all powerful so they can
solve any problems that they want and
for this talk we name the the provers
Allison Bob and the constraint we put on
the provers is that although they are
all powerful they can solve any
computational problem they cannot
communicate to each other so the only
means of communication between the
parties here are between the provers and
the verifier and an instance of this MIP
protocol will look something like this
the verifier will ask Alice a question
and also Bob a question and then we'll
get back an answer from Alice and an
answer from Bob and based off of these
answers the verifier will either say yes
I am convinced that X's in my language L
or no I remain unconvinced that X is in
the language aisle so this is a
complexity class multi proved our
interactive proofs
MIP for short and do to work bye bye bye
for now in Lund in the early 90s we do
know we have a precise characterization
of the power of this class
they showed that MIP is equal to an X so
what is NX well NX is just
non-deterministic exponential time so
it's the exponential time analog of NP
where rather than the verifier being
allowed to run in polynomial time it's
allowed to run an exponential time and a
kind of canonical problem that you might
consider non-deterministic exponential
time is the following so given an
exponential sized graph is it three
colorful or not okay so this is like the
the exponentially large version of the
three coloring problem which is an
np-complete problem but in NX you
consider of the case for the graph is
exponentially large okay so it doesn't
make sense so much sense to have inputs
that are exponential so what does it
mean to have an exponential size graph
well when we talk about this this
exponentially large graph what we're
actually talking about is the 16/3
coloring problem so in this 18:3
coloring problem your input is going to
be a boolean circuit C which encodes a
graph G sub C that has 2 to the N
vertices and how is this encoding done
well the circuit see let's say it looks
like this it's going to have two input
registers each of which consists of n
input bit wires
although the circuit encodes a graph
with an exponential number of vertices
the circuit itself is small so it's size
polynomial in n and so it can be given
as input to an algorithm and the way it
encodes this graph is as follows so it
does so using the adjacency
representation of the graph since there
are two to the N vertices the the
vertices of G sub C are in one-to-one
correspondence with the length n binary
strings and so for each vertex u in G
sub C we can associate with it a string
in 0 1 at the end and so if we have 2
vertices in G sub C u and V and we want
to know if they're connected
gee what we do is we write down their
end representation we feed the
representation for you into the first
register and the representation for V
into the second register and the circuit
C will output one if u and V are an edge
in G sub T and we'll output zero
otherwise so this circuit encodes the
graph G sub T and now your goal is to
output yes a G sub C is 3 colorable and
of course you want to help but know if
this graph is not very horrible so this
problem is in NX but not just that it's
one of the canonical annex complete
problems so it's as hard as in the other
problem in NX and because as we saw in
the last slide that MIP is equal to n X
then - all powerful perverts can
convince you that the graph G sub C is 3
colorable and why this is kind of crazy
is because this graph is exponentially
large so it's so big that you you do not
have time a polynomial time verifier
does not have time to actually you've
read the entire graph but in spite of
this if it's able to interact with two
non communicating provers it can still
become convinced that the graph is 3
colorable or not so that's MIP and this
is a sort of problem you might solve
with an MIP protocol but of course we're
talking about MIP star and it's workshop
and MIP star is just the quantum analog
event be MIP
so it's a case of my PE where Alice and
Bob are allowed to share an entangled
state and I'm gonna so it's exact same
protocol I'm gonna use these little
yellow dots to represent Alice and Bob's
share of the entangled state and so yes
these states are allowed to be entangled
they have some sort of weird quantum
correlations that go between them but as
we've seen this still does not allow
them to communicate with each other
and let me write down the standard
completeness and soundness conditions
that we have for this class so if X is
in the language L then the provers
should be able to convince the verifier
to accept and so this just means that
there should be some Alice and Bob who
share some entangled state that can
convince the verifier with probability 1
in general you can consider convincing
the verifier with probabilities lesson 1
but for this this talk will suffice just
to look at the perfect completeness case
and then if your X is not in the
language owl then it should be the case
that no matter who Alice and Bob are
they can only convince the verifier to
accept with probability at most 1/2 ok
so I'm gonna rewrite these conditions
introducing some notation that I'll
revisit in like the last slide so if X
is an L that just means that Q value of
X is equal to 1 so I'm going to write Q
value of X just to mean on this input X
what is the maximum accepting
probability that the verifier can have
so overall all pairs of provers what is
the best that the purpose can do and if
X is not in the language L then it just
means that the Q value of X should be at
most 1/2 and it's always some 1/2 you
know just an arbitrary constant so long
as it's bounded away from 1 okay so this
talk I'm just going to illustrate two
tools of the mi P star equals re result
we already saw one tool in in the talk
of Anand which is this quantum
low-degree test which we use to self
test quantum states and now I'm going to
show two more tools and as a result one
of them is called introspection and the
other one is called pcp composition I'm
gonna focus on the introspection tool
because of the two tools it's kind of
the new one for this result on the other
hand PCP composition is standard it's
been in theoretical computer science for
about 30 years now although there's
still some bells and whistles that we
need to implement it in our particular
protocol and I'm going to illustrate
these tools by start
a simple case of this MIP star equals re
result so rather than looking at the
full-blown result I'm gonna look at a
kind of a stepping stone towards this
result which was to show that MIP star
contains any exp okay so not as big as
re but any exp is still bigger than MX
and this is still like a non-trivial
result about MIP star and let me just
say what is any xB so it's the
complexity class non-deterministic
doubly exponential time so this is the
version of NP where your verifier is
allowed to run in doubly exponential
time so in time two to the two to the
polygon so it's really big and what sort
of problems do you like to consider in
on deterministic doubly exponential time
well here the canonical problem is a
problem called six cinq six inked three
coloring and it stated as follows so
just as we saw before how you can have
the polynomial size circuit that
succinctly represents an exponential
size graph you can also have a six sync
circuit which is polynomial size and
which represents an exponential size
circuit so your input in the six sync 16
3 coloring problem it's just going to be
a polynomial size or could see which
succinctly represents an exponential
size circuit C prime which itself
succinctly represents a doubly
exponential size graph G and the
question that you want to answer when
you solve this problem is just to figure
out if G is 3 colorable or not so what
what seemed wild about this result at
some point was that this graph is so big
it's doubly exponential that to even
write down the name of any vertex in
this graph requires an exponential
number of bits and so this means that
like a polynomial time verifier can't
write down the name of any vertex it
can't check a single edge in the graph
and in spite of that to quantum provers
that are all powerful and share
entanglement can convince a bear
polynomial-time verifier that this graph
is three probable okay so that's the
result that's what I'm going to tell you
about in this talk and without further
ado I'm just going to jump into it so
let me pause are there any questions
before I begin yeah I just think that
people who are not panelists you can ask
your question answer in the Q&A and then
I will read it out to John okay cool so
yeah I'm now just going to introduce
these two new tools but in the context
of these any exp contained in EM I
pieced our result so yeah so I'm going
to show you why is any exp contained an
MIP star but first actually it will be
very helpful to kind of survey this
result an e XB is equal to MIP so this
results in 30 years ago and this is a
purely classical result so an MIP if you
remember the approvers are classical
they don't share entanglement and yeah
I'm gonna do a super high level overview
they'll just give you like a couple of
the ideas from that result that are
going to be useful for our quantum
protocol so how do you show that any X V
is equal to MIP well this entails just
giving an MIP protocol for this extinct
3-coloring problem if you remember we
saw that succinctly coloring was kind of
the NEX p-complete problem the canonical
NEX peak complete problem okay so the
MIP protocol for 16/3 coloring your
input is going to be this exponential
size graph that's encoded with a
six-inch circuit and the verifier just
wants to know um is a graph through
color ball or not so let me give like
the most brain-dead kind of trivial
interactive protocol you can imagine to
solve this problem and I'm not even
going to use the second proof or Bob I'm
just going to have a single proof or
Alice and what we'd like Ellis to do is
just send the free coloring of the graph
G to the verifier and this is great
because the verify are given this three
coloring can just sit down with a graph
and check hey all the edges are properly
three colored
but there's an obvious problem with this
which is that the graph is exponentially
large and so the three coloring of the
graph requires an exponentially large
number of bits to write down and this is
simply - yeah in the meantime we had a
question in the chat regarding whether
the fraction of graphs that are
representable by 16 3 coloring is small
yeah it should be very small should be
probably an exponentially small fraction
of all graphs it's that good yeah ok
cool yeah it's still yeah it's like a
vanishingly small fraction of graphs but
still a computationally difficult a
fraction of the graphs okay so right so
where was I okay so one protocol you
could imagine for solving the 16 3
coloring problem is just to have Alice
send over the entire three coloring of
the graph G but because G is
exponentially large the three coloring
is exponentially large and this is just
um too much information for our
polynomial time very hard to read okay
but um you know that's the most natural
protocol that one could imagine and
really it seems difficult to even think
of how the provers would convince the
verifier that a graph is 3 colorable
without just giving the three coloring
to the verifier
so we have to figure out some way of
still having this protocol work but
doing it in a clever way that doesn't
require as much communication so what
we're going to do is rather than having
the approver Alice um send over the
entire three coloring we're going to
have it and clover and code it in some
clever way as a polynomial F which Maps
FQ to the M into F Q so here F Q to the
M is just a finite field over Q elements
but you know if you're uncomfortable
with this you can just pretend that it's
the integers from zero to Q minus one
that will suffice for this talk and this
can be a multivariate polynomial over F
over F Q so it has M different input
variables and we're going to set
em to be some number that's roughly a
polynomial and okay so at least to
describe a single input to F still only
requires polynomial many bits okay and
there's some clever way that they're
going to encode this 3-coloring and the
idea with this encoding is that if your
function f is actually sorry right the
idea of this 3-coloring is that when you
do a properly proper encoding of a
3-coloring of your graph what you spit
out is not just a polynomial F but a low
degree polynomial F which properly
encodes its 3-coloring and it also turns
out that for any low degree polynomial
it's easy to check whether it
corresponds to a proper 3-coloring or an
improper 3-coloring so one that at least
violates one engine in the graph okay
and let me explain for just one minute
why would you even think of encoding a
3-coloring with a polynomial so the
basic idea here is as follows if you're
not able to read the entire tree
coloring one idea that you might have is
well maybe we can just pick a vertex U
and a vertex V in the graph and just
look at the three coloring on these two
vertices what what three coloring what
coloring does it assign these vertices
and just check that on this edge you're
you're properly colored so what's an
issue with that well if the three
coloring is improper so it violates an
edge it might only violate a single edge
in the entire graph and because the
graph is exponentially large the odds of
you correctly picking that one edge are
very small okay and so what we'd like to
do is yeah it's our question
okay I wanted to ask oh I wanted to ask
so like coloring a tree carving is just
a function from the vertices to two the
three colors yeah many such functions it
seems that they are much less loading
the polynomials so why is it even
possible to represent them as loading to
degree polynomials oh so it's not going
to be it's not gonna be like a by
ejected map mapping so for for some of
the low degree polynomials
some of the low degree polynomials will
correspond to three colorings of the
graph some of those polynomials will
correspond to proper three colorings of
the graph some will correspond to
improper through colorings of the graph
and then there will be a whole nother
set of three colorings which don't
correspond to any tree coloring of the
graph but you are saying that the set of
low degree polynomials is like is as
large at least as the set of three
colorings yeah yeah
if you said like the degree parameters
right and yeah you want Q to be big you
want em to be large enough but I mean
notice okay I picked em to be like oh
yeah yeah so if you if you just set all
the parameters correctly there is a way
to get many more low degree polynomials
thing up there Clarins I see okay yeah
so um yeah I was explaining why why do
these low degree polynomials come up so
again you'd like to pick a random edge
maybe and see if you have a violation on
that edge but a random edge will you'll
typically not see a violation so you'd
like some way of amplifying a single
incorrect edge into many edges that are
incorrect so if you pick a random edge
you will actually see a violation and a
natural way of doing that it's using an
error correcting code and an air
correcting code is a way of taking a
single error and blowing it up into
errors and main different places and so
you can just kind of spot-check randomly
and find an error and as it turns out
this low degree polynomial
encoding of three colorings is an error
correcting code okay so that's why you
might consider a low degree polynomial
encoding and so now on the provers what
the high vis L will have this polynomial
F and again if it's low degree it's easy
to check that it corresponds to with
proper 3-coloring but maybe the prefers
are lying to you maybe they have a
polynomial F which is not low degree and
so they're gonna try to trick you into
thinking it's a 3-coloring
by not actually having a low degree
polynomial so in this protocol that I
might be protocol the main task is
actually just testing that this
polynomial F is actually a low degree
and once you can do that if you can
verify that it's a low degree then it's
easy to check that it's up for coloring
and how do you verify that a polynomials
low degree well it's done by something
called the wine versus point low degree
test okay so what is the line versus
point low degree test so again your goal
in this test is to check whether this
polynomial F which Maps FQ to the M in
the FQ is a low degree polynomial and so
you're going to do it in the following
steps in step one you're going to pick a
point you in FQ the VM uniformly at
random
you'll also pick another point V in FQ
to the M uniformly at random and you're
just going to name that your direction
okay so it's a point in sq to the N but
we call it the direction and in addition
to having the point you we're going to
define the line L as follows it's going
to be the line L that passes through you
in Direction V so it contains all the
points u plus T times V where T ranges
over all elements of FQ so it's gonna
you know contain U and u plus V u plus 2
V and so on and what is a verifier are
going to do with Alice and Bob well the
verifier is going to send the line L to
Alice and the verifier is going to send
the point you to Bob and Alice and Bob
are going to reply with some answers
that are formatted in this specific way
I'll talk about this a little bit in a
second and the way you click up this
protocol is that given these answers the
verifier can actually tell if your
function f is low degree okay so um as
we're going to see throughout this
protocol or throughout this talk the the
what these answers are is not important
at all which is why I haven't specified
them here but just in case you're
interested what Bob is supposed to reply
with is the function f evaluated at U so
Bob is supposed to say F of U and Alice
who is given this line L is supposed to
reply with a low degree polynomial along
the line L and the check that the
verifier is going to do is the verifier
is going to check that the polynomial
that alice gives it evaluated at U is
equal to Bob's value F of U ok and if
these two things agree with high
probability then it must be that F is
actually a low degree polynomial
okay notice um something interesting
about this protocol the way that it's
set up um Alice and Bob are are non
communicating provers okay so they don't
know the question that the other one is
given so if alice is given owl she can't
tell what Bob what line she was given
and if Bob is given the point u he can't
tell Alice which point he's given but
they're given partial information about
each other's questions
so Alice knows that along her line
somewhere is Bob's point she just
doesn't know which point it is and Bob
he's given a point and he knows that
Alice's line is just some line that
passes through that point but he doesn't
know which line it is so they both are
given in complete and partial
information about the other previous
question okay but for our purposes it's
not important what all these details are
so it doesn't matter what the answers
are supposed to be it doesn't matter
what the verifier is except condition
all that matters is that this is
basically the main subroutine in this NX
protocol this MIT protocol for M X so
you know when I talk about this protocol
in the future just think the line versus
point low degree test and the other
thing that matters is the format's of
the questions so that the questions are
a line L and a point you located on the
line
all right so that was um MIP equals MX
so now I'm going to move on to MIP star
contains in any exp and this is where
we're going to see introspection and PCP
composition so before I move on are
there any questions
okay all right so how do we show that
any exp is contained in my P star well
this just entails giving an MIP star
protocol for the succinctly coloring
problem which if you remember was the
canonical any exp complete problem so
now rather than our input being an
exponential size graph or input is a W
exponential size graph and I don't know
so now we have to devise a protocol for
this and one idea is just well you know
we're not very creative so let's just
use the same protocol we saw on the last
slide so in other words the provers have
some sort of coloring for for this graph
they should encode it using a polynomial
F and then the verifier is suspicious of
them so the verifier runs a low degree
test on that
when that protocol would look something
like this the verifier wants to know of
g is and is 16 16 3 colorable so it's
going to send the line L to Alice and
the point u to Bob and it's going to get
back the answer is ante and ants B from
Alice and Bob respectively but of course
we have the obvious problem which is
that all this is fine and dandy when the
graph is exponentially large the
verifier you know runs in polynomial
time and so is asking questions outward
sized polynomial is receiving back
answers there were sized polynomial and
everything was peachy but now the graph
is doubly exponentially large so it's
exponentially bigger than once before
and so this blows up all the parameters
by a factor of exponential MN so now the
line in point rather than being
polynomial bits they're exponential and
the answers that are received rather
than being polynomial are also
exponentially large and this is a
problem because our small polynomial
time verifier is simply not powerful
enough to read read these questions and
answers so we could think of this as one
problem which is that all the
communication is just exponentially
large but actually in this talk we're
going to split it up into two separate
problems so one of the problems is that
the questions are just too long and the
second problem is that the answers are
too long and this talk what it's going
to do is it's going to solve each of
these problems one by one
okay so the outline is going to be as
follows we have this protocol for 16th
16th 3-coloring where the
question-and-answer sizes are both
exponentially large so first we're going
to do something called question
reduction we question reduce and this
will bring down the questions from
exponentially large to just size Pauline
polynomial and n it will do this while
keeping the answers of size polynomial
size exponential in n so the answers
will still be big but the questions will
be small after doing classroom reduction
will do answer reduction and this will
also bring down the answers to size
polynomial and M so step one is involves
the quantum so this is why we have an
MIP star protocol rather than my P
protocol and it's also kind of the more
interesting of the two steps so this is
so like I said this is one that involves
quantum it's the one that involves a lot
of new ideas whereas the answer
reduction it's a bit more standard and
so I'm going to focus mostly on step one
in this talk all right so question
reduction so the key idea of our
question reduction protocol is the
following the questions that we have
right now are exponentially long which
are too long for a verifier to sample
but we have to prove ourselves and Bob
who are omnipotent and so sampling these
exponentially long questions should be a
piece of cake for them so the idea that
we want that we have is to just simply
delegate the sampling of the questions
to Alice and Bob make them do all the
work for us and so if this is our
protocol right now the verifier you know
it sends out L and U to Alice and Bob
and it gets back the two answers we'd
preferred if our protocol looked
something like this
so what we would love is if rather than
the verifier sampling the line and the
point we'd love it if Alice and Bob
sampled the line at a point themselves
and sent it to the verifier so it would
be great if Alice and Bob just told us
the questions that we would have asked
them and then not only that it would it
be great if Alice would say not only is
here the why
here's a line that you would have pulled
me but had you given me this line here
is the answer I would have responded
with and it would be great if Bob would
also in addition to him telling us a
point you it'd be great if he also told
us the answer that he would have given
us had we asked him the question you so
we call this idea introspection because
the provers are introspecting so rather
than us asking them the questions they
are asking themselves the questions and
this would be great it has a lot of
pretty obvious problems with it which
I'll address on next slide but kind of
the most basic thing that you'd need to
get this to work is a source of shared
randomness right because Alice and Bob
need some sort of shared randomness to
be able to sample their line and their
point which are your mother kind of
uniformly distributed in FQ to the M so
how what might we would do this for sure
grandma's well let's imagine the most
simple model of shared randomness that
Alice and Bob could have so suppose
Alice and Bob had access to a shared
cake
what do I mean by a shared cape well
just imagine you know Alice and Bob are
sitting there in their rooms or
somewhere in the galaxy and just in the
sky somewhere it's just like a sequence
of zeros and ones so a sequence of zero
ones that goes on forever
you're just uniformly random in
independent bits but they can both look
up into the sky and see and it'd be
great if Alice and Bob using their
shared cape just agreed ahead of time
that the first chunk of it was going to
correspond to the random point you and
it'd be great if they also agree that
the second chunk of it will correspond
to the random direction V enough Q to
the M so supposing we gave them the
shirt tape what would really be nice is
if Alice just told us the line L that
passes through you in Direction V okay
and it would be great if Bob told us the
point you
and if they were able to do that if they
did that then they would be
introspectively sampling the questions
that we were supposed to be giving them
okay
but there are some obvious problems with
this which shows us that that shared
randomness is simply not enough to carry
out this idea and a problem number one
is just that Alice and Bob could lie
right there's no reason why Alice is
forced to tell you the line through you
indirection fee she could just tell you
a different line and simple is similarly
Bob could lock up on the shared tape he
could see the point you and instead of
telling you you he could tell you a
different point you Prime in other words
you know Alice and Bob could always tell
you lines and points that are easy for
them to answer maybe they can maybe they
would just avoid asking like the hard
questions and only ever ask themselves
the easy questions and there's no way
for you to check that ok I'm another
problem which is seems even more
fundamental is even if they were being
honest they can still see each other's
questions so Alice can see Bob's point
and Bob can see both U and V and so he
knows Alice's line l and so if the two
prefers know each other's questions then
we've defeated the entire purpose of
having multiple approvers to begin with
they can now act as a single proofer so
what we really need is a source of
shared randomness that the verifier can
control and a source of shared
randomness where the verifier can
prevent these two cheating strategies
from happening and the sense of shared
randomness that we're going to use is
entangled quantum states so yeah we've
seen a lot of integral quantum states so
as we all know entangled quantum states
are if form of shared randomness between
two parties and the way that we're going
to use these entangled States is using
these protocols that we've seen in
previous talks these self testing
protocols so we saw
draya's talk and unknowns talk and these
are protocols which give the verifier
control over the prover state and the
way they interact with it um in
particular if you run one of these
protocols you can force the provers to
share a specific quantum state and not
only that you can force them to perform
specific quantum measurements on the
state and of course when I say a quantum
protocol here I specifically mean an MIP
star protocol so if it's exactly within
the model what we're looking at so it's
one of these protocols with a verifier
will ask questions to the provers get
back answers and if the provers pass the
test with high enough probability then
they must be satisfying items 1 and 2 so
this seems promising and really our goal
now is to find one of these self tests
where the state and measurements that
you get out of it correspond in some
manner to the line versus point
distribution which is the distribution
that we want them to introspectively
sample
so the protocol we're going to use is
this quantum low degree test which uh
none described in his talk this is from
joint work with on on nitrogen and to
lymphatic and what their result says at
a high level is a following using this
quantum low degree test you can command
your provers to do two things number one
you can force them to share an
exponentially large number of entangled
qubits and number two you can force them
to perform specific types of
measurements that I'm going to call
total X and Pelosi measurements and I'll
explain a little bit more about those
later and not only that even though
you're forcing the approvers to share an
exponentially large number of entangled
qubits the question size that the
verifier has only polynomial name
okay so this seems great for us because
if you remember we want the verifiers or
we sorry we want the provers to have to
be able to sample these lines of points
that are exponentially long and so they
need some sorts of shared randomness
that has an exponential number of bits
and that seems to be what number one is
giving us but at the same time we're
we're in question reduction and so we
want the verifier to have questions that
are size not exponential but polynomial
and again that seems like something that
this this test gives us all right so
what does this mean
what are these total x in total z
measurements well we have to understand
what these things mean and rather than
really going into what these are I mean
if you if you know what these are this
is just the measurements of the the
provers perform by either measuring all
of their qubits in the X or the Z basis
and so hopefully some of you know
exactly what that is but if not I'm just
going to give you a toy model that
suffice is to kind of capture all the
interesting properties about this and
yeah we'll show you exactly how this
introspection works so this toy model
I'm going to call it the EPR toy model
and you know Alice and Bob are sharing
an entangled quantum state but for now
I'm gonna forget about Bob and I'm just
going to look at Alice and her entangled
quantum state you know on her side it
corresponds to some number of qubits but
I'm going to ignore qubits and all Alice
has access to is something I'm going to
call an EPR box
so this EPR box is literally just like a
box there's two registers one labeled Z
one labeled X and the Z register is
going to be a string a and s Q to the M
which sampled uniformly at random and in
the X register is another string B and
FQ to the M sampled uniformly at random
and independently of P now alice is not
going to be able to interact with the
EPR box by just looking at it so she's
not we're not allowing her to just look
at a or look at me instead her her
interactions are via something that we
called the Z dot product table so she's
going to have sitting
next to her EP our box another table
consisting of all the Z dot products
what does that mean what's going to
contain all the dot products of strings
and fq to the M with her string a so
it's gonna have a dot all zeros which is
just zero a dot all zeros one dot all
the way down to a dot all ones actually
you know this is over FQ so that should
be a dot you know Q minus 1 Q minus 1 mm
so in particular for any strings ee + fq
2 BM there's going to be some entry on
this table that will tell you the dot
product of a MZ all right and similarly
for the x register rather than being
able to read the entire string B Alice
is allowed to just look at the X dot
products so she's gonna have this other
table and for every X in FQ DDM there's
going to be an entering this table that
tells her B dot X all right so she has
these two tables of dot products sitting
there in space there's going to be one
more rule that specifies how Alice is
able to interact with these tables which
says that when she reads some of the
entries of these tables it will erase
some other entries of the tables
so in particular whenever Alice reads to
sell a dot C she erases each sell B dot
X such that Z dot X is not equal to 0
and vice versa
so she reads a sell B dot X then she has
to erase each sell a dot Z such that Z X
it's not equal to 0 so pictorially what
might happen on Alice's side is the
following maybe she's going to read a
certain string Z in the Z dot product
table and the effect that we'll have is
to erase some of the entries in the X
dot product table so she can no longer
access those and now maybe she wants to
read some entry X in the X dot product
table and that will entail erasing some
of the entries and the Z dot product
tables and maybe she wants to read
another string X Prime in the X dot
product table and that will entail
erasing more entries in the Z table
people
all right so um all right so that's a
lot of information to throw so let me go
through a couple of examples I will
hopefully give you an intuition for how
this works so example number one suppose
um Alice goes to the X dot product table
and just reads the entries bei for each
I so here AI is the 8th standard basis
vector it has a 1 in entry I and zeros
and all the other entries well what's
that going to tell her she's gonna learn
the value of BI the I scored and a B for
each I and therefore she's going to know
the entire string B so she's read
basically the entire X register but now
suppose she wants to go to the Z
register and learn something about a
what can what can she learn about it
well that's dictated by that rule that
we just saw and suppose she wants to
read maybe an entry Z and in the table
well every nonzero Z has a nonzero
coordinate I and therefore that
coordinate I has a property that Zi is
not equal to 0 for that I and because we
already read AI in the X dot product
table this will tell us that the entry a
dot Z is erased in the Z dot product
people and because this happens for
every nonzero Z the entire Z dot product
table is going to be erased and as a
result we will have no information about
a so in other words if we read all the X
dot product table we erase everything in
the Z table pretty table this is what
I'm going to call a total X measurement
because she's learning all of the X
information but none of the Z
information and you can define total Z
measurements similarly
okay the second example is as follows
suppose Alice goes to the Excel product
table and reads be1
then our rule tells us that you can't
learn any a dot Z if Z 1 is not equal to
0 so she can only read ad where Z has
another Oh first coordinate so she wants
she could read the entries a di
for each I not equal to 1 so she could
read 8283 and so on and what this would
tell her are the values a 2 3 a but not
a 1 so if she reads be taught you one
she's prohibited from learning the first
bit at a but she can learn all the other
points okay so that's Alice's side of
the equation what does Bob see well he
gets his own EPR box and his box is
filled with the exact same a and the
same D so you know for example both of
them do total Zee measurements both of
them will get the strings a it both of
them do total X measurements both of
them will get the strings B and if one
does a total X measurement and the other
one does a total Z measurement the mole
look at the string a and the other one
will get the string B and so we see how
different ways of accessing these boxes
will give them different levels of
correlations between the information
that they get all right so I promised
you that this was somehow a good model
for entangled quantum state so why
should this look like it's a good model
for this why should it look physics edu
well number one it looks like there's
some sort of entanglement here because
Alice and Bob have this sort of shared
information in their boxes it's also
physics e because it has this like
Heisenberg uncertainty principle aspect
to it you know that says that like a
particle if you learn it's it's
positioned and you have to erase this
momentum but similarly here if you learn
like Z information you have to erase X
information ok so we have some sort of
uncertainty principle stuff going on
here and finally this is like non
signalling as well which is a property
that quantum mechanics has
can use these boxes to correlate but
they can't use them to communicate
alright so the summary thus far as we
saw before using the quantum low-degree
test you can force approvers to share
these EPR MQ boxes and you can also
force them to do total X or total Z
measurements on these boxes
and not only that when you use this test
and force them to have boxes of size M
the questioned size that you have is
only logarithmic Annette so again you
remember we want them to have an
exponential number of of bits that
they're sampling so here M will be
exponential and so this will give us
boxes that contain exponentially long
strings but our question size will be
only polynomial and our goal is for Bob
to sample a point you in FQ to be M
uniformly at random and for Alice to
sample a direction V and F Q to the N
uniformly at random and then to sample
the line L which goes through you in
Direction B okay well I'm gonna ignore
the fact that V is uniformly at random
let's just fix V for now let's ignore
the issue of sampling V and just fix of
V and in fact let's just do this for V
being like the most trivial vector I can
imagine which is a 1 in the first
coordinate and 0 elsewhere okay so how
can we get them to sample a point and
then a line through this point in that
direction
okay so the way we're gonna do it using
the low degree test we can now force
them to share the EP art boxes and I'm
going to begin by suggestively renaming
the entering the first cell from a ATU
okay so the verifier is going to tell
Bob to do a Z total measurement and
because we've done the quantum low
degree test bob has to do Lissie total
measurement and so what he's going to do
he's going to look in the Z register
read off the the U and report that back
and so now we've we sampled this random
point and so now we just want Alice to
learn the line L that goes through you
in Direction one zero zero zero zero one
thing we could tell Alice to do is just
also do a Z total measurement and what
she would do if that happened was she
would just learn all of you and that'd
be enough - to learn this line l as well
but of course we want her to learn the
line L without learning you
so um as it turns out to learn the line
l but not you is equivalent to learning
the values you two through um but not
you one well why is that it's because
every point in L agrees with you on
coordinates two through them but the
other points will disagree with you on
the first coordinate so every possible
value for the first coordinate will
occur somewhere along this line but all
the other coordinates will agree with
you and so once you learn you two
through um you learn all the points in
line L and therefore you learn oh I know
so we just need her to learn these these
values you two through um and we want to
have some sort of certificate that she
also does not learn you one but this is
exactly our second example that we saw
earlier if we can get her to measure B 1
then this will prohibit her from
learning you on but then to is also able
to learn the values you two through um
okay so we want her to tell us B 1 and u
2 through um and now we just have to
check that she act honestly and why
don't we get this necessarily for free
well neither of these things that she's
reporting back to us our total X or
total Zee measurements is some sort of
intermediate between a total X and total
Zee measurement
okay so what we're going to do to check
she acts honestly it's just half the
time we're going to tell Bob to do is
eat all the measurement he'll measure
the entire string honestly and we just
check her you eyes against his and
because he's acting honestly she will be
acting on it honestly and the other half
of the time will tell Bob to do an X
total measurement and he'll read the
entire string B and we can just check
her B one against his and again because
he's acting honestly she has to be
acting honestly okay so that's it I mean
that lines with this particular
direction and now let's imagine how
would we do the case when the direction
isn't fixed to one zero zero zero but
it's just some other general direction
and we're gonna start similarly before
just reminder that we are approaching
the end of the talk like you have like
five more minutes to wrap up would it be
sufficient I might have to go over by
five okay
maybe yeah I mean we have like three
more meet scheduled so do you think that
in like I don't know it means you can
yeah hopefully let's see okay okay
so this is a general direction V yeah
how do we do this case well the verifier
will tell Bob again to just to do a Z
total measurement and again we want
Alice to learn the line through you and
Direction V but not the point you and so
it's just an exercise just as before
we're all we had to do was get Alves to
read one entry in the X dot product
table for here it suffice is to have
Alice measure the entry B dot B and it
turns out as she measures this it will
she still has enough information of the
Z dot product able to learn the line l
but she will not be able to learn
anything more about the point
all right so that was question reduction
in summary how did it work well we used
introspection to have the provers sample
the questions for us and we use
entanglement to between them to have
them jointly sample from the line versus
point distribution but we use the
uncertainty principle to hide the
information about the other players
questions similar ideas work for the
other questions in the 1616 3-coloring
protocol so you know I told you that
this protocol was mostly the line versus
point low degree test it was kind of
alive and there's some other interesting
things that go on there but we can use
similar ideas to handle the other
questions that arise there and this
established as a result any exp is
contained an MIP star with polynomial
size questions and exponential size
answers okay but now we also want to do
answer reduction and let me just very
briefly describe how this works in
answer reduction we have our protocol
that looks like this
the verifier it has Alice and Bob they
have their quantum states verifier ask
questions it gets back answers and the
questions are size polynomial but now
the answer is our size exponential and
we'd like to reduce thank you yeah Joe
you have a question about whether it is
because of entanglement that it doesn't
matter if Alice or Bob lies I guess or
like how to catch whether they try to
lie right it's exactly this property the
self test so the self test if if they
pass the self test with high probability
this is the quantum low-degree test if
they pass with the sufficiently high
probability then they can't be lying
they have to be honest that they're
performing these total accent open C
measurements and then we can bootstrap
the honesty that they have for total X -
10 total Zee measurements to force them
to also you know correctly sample the
lines and the points
okay all right so the answers are too
long to read and that's a problem for
our polynomial time verifier to check
and so what we'd like the verifier to be
able to do is check if it should accept
the answer is a a and a B but it'd be
nice if you could do it without reading
all of a a and so can it can they check
that they should accept the answers
without actually reading all the answers
and let me just say the solution here is
yes you can do it using this these ideas
of probabilistically checkable proof
from the computer science literature's
and since I'm short on time I'm kind of
going to skip over exactly how these
things work but in general
probabilistically checkable proofs they
allow you to verify may be a very large
statement by only checking a small
number of bits from the statement that
you're trying to check and so the
verifier rather than receiving the
entire answers from Alice and Bob will
instead only ask for Alice and Bob to
send back you know a small subset of the
bits of the answers the verifier are
only reading those bits we'll still be
able to check that it checks that the
answer is a a and a B and well I have
some more details on this if you want I
have two slides so if people are
interested I can talk about that later
there's some annoying details they have
to get through but let me talk about
compression because I have to state the
compression theorem our result here is
basically a compression theorem so what
do we do
we took this protocol which we got from
the MIP equals MX protocol it was a big
protocol I mean it dealt with
exponentially large answers and
questions and we applied some sort of
compression ideas we somehow managed to
shrink this protocol to one where all
the Exponential's were compressed down
to polynomials and this will allow us to
show that any exp is contained in my P
star
but you might ask I mean why only do one
random compression instead of taking a
big protocol and compressing it down to
a small protocol why not start from a
very big protocol compressing it down to
a big protocol and then compressing it
down to a smaller protocol or I mean why
not do this three times or four times or
whatever so this was inspired by a prior
work of jianxing G and a paper of
Fitzsimmons and all kind of jangbang
introduced this idea of compression and
then Fitzsimmons
at all study what happens when you
repeatedly apply a compression procedure
so in our case what would this look like
well our first compression is what I did
in this talk we started with this may a
protocol that had the low degree test
and using introspection we were able to
compress it with the quantum law degree
test so now we have a new protocol maybe
the main aspect of it is this quantum
low degree test and it allows us to
compress the low-degree test in some
sense so if we wanted to compress us
again well we now have a protocol where
the main subroutine in it is a quantum
low degree test and you might ask can we
introspect the questions from that that
that test well it's not clear I mean
it's not the low degree test I showed
you how to introspect the low degree
test what about the quantum world degree
test I don't know but it turns out the
main subroutine in the quantum law
degree test is a little green test so I
mean that gives you some hope maybe we
can use similar ideas to introspect that
and that would give us some result of
compressing again and then maybe we want
to compress again a third time so now we
start with whatever protocol we get at
the output of the second compression you
might ask can we compress that and so on
and so this this will continue on for a
while I mean every time you compress
you're gonna get some new tests that you
need to introspect the questions from
the previous protocol and things might
get very complicated but um one of our
main results in this paper was that we
can actually compress any protocol which
looks like the law degree test and at
least for this talk you can just think
of these protocols as maybe general I
would agree test though as you'll see
Jake thank talk about in the next talk
there's a technical definition of what
these things
which are conditional linear functions
so let me just state the compression
theorem and then I'll end here
the compression theorem rather than
being applied to non local games or MIT
star protocols it's actually just
applied to non local games we've seen
these a bit already and it's actually
applied to uniform families of non-local
games so what is a uniform family of a
non-local game well just one that is
specified that you can compute with the
Turing machine G so in other words you
know I have a Turing machine I have a
program I feed in the number n and it
will output the description of a
non-local game G sub n and if you do
this for all different inputs you you
can have then this Turing machine
naturally encodes a family of non-local
games G 1 through
and the compression theorem is as
follows we give the the we show the
existence of a Turing machine that we
call compress and it takes as input a
Turing machine that encodes one of these
uniform families of non-local games and
it outputs another Turing machine which
encodes a different uniform family of
non-local games H and you know the first
string machine encodes the family g13 g2
dot a sequence of them the second one it
causes family h 1 h 2 dot dot and the
idea is that you want the non-local game
h sub n to simulate the non-local game G
sub n plus 1 so you want to compress
your family down a level you want to
shift everything over one level so you
know H Sablan should simulate G sub 2 h
sub 2 should simulate u s-- at 3 and so
on and what do we mean by simulate well
we have the following three conditions
first off if the value of the quantum
value of the game G sub n plus 1 is
equal to 1 and then the quantum value of
the game H of n should also be equal to
1 so to preserve the value of the game
it's not too bad the second condition
deals with this this quantity eh and 1/2
and this is just the number of entangled
bits Alice and Bob need if they want to
succeed with value at least 1/2 okay so
in general you know in our games we want
our provers to be sharing a lot of
entangled bit so in a lot of these games
you expect that these values won't be
large and what our theorem says is that
the number of entangled bits that the
approvers will need to share to achieve
value 1/2 in game h of n will be at
least the number of bits that they need
to achieve value 1/2 and game G of n
plus 1 ok so that's again that you're
kind of simulating that game it's also
going to be lower bounded they will also
need to share some entangled bits
corresponding to the length of the
questions in bits of game G sub n plus 1
and this is might seem weird but if you
remember what were we using some of our
entanglement before it was too
as shared randomness to introspectively
sample the questions from our games and
so similarly here when we compress we're
going to force the provers to share some
number of entangled bits so that they
can sample the questions from GM plus
one
alright so because it's a lower bound by
both of these it's definitely lower
bounded by the max of these and then the
final thing is that the complexity of H
sub n should be poly logarithmic in the
complexity of G sub n plus 1 and so what
does that mean well let's say G sub n
plus 1 has a verifier and maybe it runs
in exponential time then we'd like to
the verifier in the in h event only run
in polynomial time so okay we preserve
two properties the quantum value and the
amount of entanglement that you need to
do well while shrinking the complexity
and exponential amount and that's our
compression theorem a technical point
again this only works if the game G is
one of these generalized low-degree
tests that I mentioned earlier but this
compression theorem also outputs an H
which is also a generalized slow degree
test and as a result you can repeatedly
apply this compression over and over
again to your heart's desire
all right and once you've established
this as jangbang we'll talk about it in
his talk this is sufficient to imply a
result and my P star equals Rd and
that's all I have so thanks for
listening okay so let's thank John yeah
I guess we if there are some more
questions then people can ask that while
we be a reason with the next talk in a
quarter an hour like a half past three